Michelle is with us in Kentucky hi
Michelle how are you good how are you
better than I deserve what's up I think
so much for taking my call and been
following you and your plan for the last
17 years and I'm just wondering once you
pay off all your debt and I have my own
business and it's how do you stomach the
reoccurring cost and feeling like that
you have debt again I don't but it
because of the reoccurring cost and
having slow months it feels like that
and sorry what I mean in your business
you have recurring coughs yes like what
um like Halo and and marketing cost and
things like that are you making a profit
so I have been in the past so I've been
in business for a little under five
years and the starting the first year
made more money than I ever made and and
then every year after that made even
more money and this year has been the
worst year so far out of the five years
and more so this year we're just barely
getting by I think the market has
shifted and I'm in real estate and the
markets starting to change some and so
when you look in the pipeline you don't
see enough coming in to cover you for
the next few months for your expenses um
I mean how do you ever said anything
back for a retained earnings you know I
mean business savings never slow times I
have about 100,000 total saved but from
to run my household and my business
about 19,000 a month and when you see
you know okay we're gonna have three to
six thousand and months come in over the
next couple months and you know how you
just kind of stomachs that or when you
say you know I have to get rid of this
marketing cost or you know but that also
is what brings the reoccurring costs are
not a problem to you quit making money I
mean I've got 900 team members on
payroll and I don't lay awake worrying
about the payroll and it's by far the
largest expense around here not even
close but what what does what you do
have to do is you have to stay out ahead
of it on the revenue side and what
you're seeing is a drop in revenue and
what's really bothering you is not the
recurring costs it's that you don't see
the revenue coming back up cuz if you
saw the revenue being 40,000 a month you
wouldn't be worried about this right but
you don't see that and so the recurring
costs aren't what are stressing you it's
the lack of revenue that's stressing you
right so what are we gonna do to get the
revenue up or we're gonna have to cut
some of these people right cuz this is
good that what you just told me has
about a four month burn rate and you're
gonna be at the end exactly yeah so it
you know like I I know from being from
running businesses in the past that you
know there's slow months but it it's you
know when you say is it just a slow
month or has the market shifted market
shipping is a market shifting my finger
deals in a slow month right the whole
years and slow like were take-home pay
or today for me it's like to this pay my
bills person always been like thirty
thousand yeah I think what you get is
get back out in front of it and reset
your business and say what has to be
true for us to get revenues back up
where this is fun again and if I can't
see my way to make those things happen
what has to be true then what has to be
true is you got to cut a bunch of
expenses and you got to cut them quick
but but don't do that do the first one
right the market shifted so go find it
who moved my cheese you read the book
yeah I don't know Baba go get the book
it's my Spencer Johnson who moved my
cheese it's a classic takes about 40
minutes to read it but the thing about
the markets is they always shift I mean
when I started in this when I started
this business there was no internet and
now 80% of our revenues are
internet-based one way or another and so
digitally based in some kind of a
methodology so the markets are always
shifting markets are always being
disrupted and you you need to stay out
ahead of it enough you want to be that
some kind of profit what you guys stay
out ahead of it enough that you can ride
the wave of the market shift rather than
get crushed by it and what you're
feeling is you see this wave this
tsunami coming at you and you don't feel
like you got a surfboard you know right
so I think you back up with some fresh
eyes chill breathe get up early watch
the Sun come up spend some time with
prayer with the Bible open in your lap
and start saying okay let's pretend this
was a brand-new business in today's
world where would I go get the money if
I was really excited and smiling again
and then go get that money girl you know
how to do it okay this is revenue you
need to chase that revenue down and
tackle it you used to do that yep and
you kind of got to doing the same thing
over and over again and now it's not
working
right I think the market probably did
move on you a little bit but I don't
think I don't think it moved I don't
think it moved away I think it moved and
you just it's down to exits you've got
to drive down there and find it you know
that kind of thing and that's what we're
we fight that around here every day that
is a normal healthy fear of the
entrepreneur the editor of Success
Magazine used to say the entrepreneur is
the only person who can go from sheer
terror to sheer exhilaration and back
every 24 hours and that it such is the
nature of the beast for those of us that
are entrepreneurs it's just how we think
so
hope that helps
thanks for the call